c'était une journée portes ouvertes dans
les fermes pour les élèves de primaire
organisée par la fnsea pour mieux faire
connaître les métiers de l'agriculture
et de l'élevage à des élèves souvent
sita dans cette initiative
on a enchanté plus d'un cheval une
classe en plein air pour la journée avec
déjeuner et cour de récréation un peu
spécial l'occasion aussi pour la
nouvelle présidente de la fnsea de
rappeler l'attachement du monde agricole
à une production de qualité respectueuse
de l'environnement est proche des
consommateurs
mais cela a un prix vous aurez pas des
prairies de ce type là des animaux de ce
type là
s'il n'y a pas la clé des prix
rémunérateur pour les producteurs c'est
un tout et désormais les consommateurs
souhaitent mieux connaître l'origine des
produits qu'ils achètent ils n'hésitent
plus à venir acheter directement à la
ferme leur viande comme chez cet éleveur
qui a près de 150 bovins
ils savent comment je travaille ils
voient comment nourrir les animaux
ils sont nés à la ferme ils sont
ils passent toute leur vie sur
l'exploitation à manger de l'herbe du
foin et cetera l'hiver etc
ils savent comment ils sont élevés et
nourris une journée pour changer un peu
l'image d'un monde agricole en pleine
mutation
les agriculteurs souhaitent désormais
avec ces nouveaux ambassadeurs se
rapprocher des consommateurs soucieux de
transparence de traçabilité et de
qualité
d'autres journées portes ouvertes sont
déjà prévus